foreign
[Music]
there's nothing down there
we made sure of that
what do you got there
this old [__] is a gold miner
you got gold in those bags
take a look at this
boys
put it
foreign
get down on your knees
bags are full of gold
[Laughter]
get down on your knees Grandpa
shoot the [__]
[__] him up
[Laughter]
we got gold
[Music]
get off the house
this old [__] is a gold miner
we're rich boys
get down on your knees
[__] him up
here is a finished Commander lost his
home and his family in the war he became
a one-man Death Squad
he's one mean [__] that you do
not want to mess with
[Music]
fire
you'll see what happens when you take
everything from him
do you really believe that he's Immortal
no he just refuses to die how many Minds
did you bury here all of them
you
and you
this is not about who's the strongest
this is about not giving up
we have a word for that in Finland
[Music]
we might have a problem